hey youtubers it's Charlie so I have a
couple trailers for the flash and
Supergirl that I'm going to break down
as well as talk a little bit about
Supergirl episode 2 so I'm gonna do
Supergirl stuff first and then I'm gonna
do the flash here we go
this train is a gift for National City
get people out of their gas guzzlers an
accepting of cleaning affordable
transportation it has to be perfect
hello I'm looking for someone with a
background in nuclear fission no
volunteers how about you
it's okay you wanna keep calm it's gonna
be alright
you don't need to hurt him
I need this man looks at things what you
need is a mechanical genius compared to
me that guy's a dope don't take him take
me not always seems to work so a lot of
you might be familiar with reactron from
the comics he's been a huge Supergirl
villain huge power girl villain for a
long time originally in the classic
Supergirl comics he debuted as a mutant
that's where his powers came from his
power is to generate radiation like he
generates blasts of pure radiation later
in the comics they give him different
types of Kryptonite just to modify the
way he's able to fight Kryptonians
so he gets powered with green kryptonite
is very deadly he gets powered with gold
kryptonite it takes their powers away
briefly you get the idea he was a really
big character during the Superman New
Krypton storyline obviously that was a
big Brainiac story mostly but he just he
appeared in a big part of it so if you
want to read a good reactron story just
go back and read New Krypton in the
context of the show because Maxwell Lord
is gonna be the big bad of the show he
might be the way reactron gets energized
with kryptonite we see Supergirl
punching the [ __ ] out of him obviously
he's already very powerful without
kryptonite but I'm wondering if he's
gonna get supercharged at the end of the
episode just looking at this clip it's
kind of hard to tell if Maxwell Lord
knows who he is but he's just he's
putting himself out there is incredibly
smart like please take me there's no way
I'm a powerful telepath that'll be able
to mind-control you you can imagine the
direction the show is gonna take with
this Maxwell Lord mind controlling
villains to go up against Supergirl when
he wants most of the Maxwell Lord clips
that they posted show nothing of his
abilities just that he's really smart
he's a tech billionaire but I definitely
think that we will see him use his power
in some subtle way you know maybe in
like the end teaser probably not right
away when we first meet him there
probably is gonna put him forward as a
normal person typically when the design
shows like this like they understand
that a lot of people have read the
comics but most of the times they make
it for a more general audience so they
probably won't immediately tip their hat
that he's a telepath but episode 2 hank
henshaw glowing red eyes what does that
mean there are two big possibilities one
hank henshaw is really true to the
comics and he will be cyborg superman or
two he is
martian manhunter in disguise it's just
that every single time martian manhunter
shows up on a TV show either animated or
live-action his eyes glow red just like
that but the thing is they gave him the
name of a very notable Superman villain
so changing that and making hank henshaw
martian manhunter would be a huge WTF
unless it's Martian Manhunter just
disguising himself using a pseudonym
he's not the real Hank Henshaw so I'm
gonna go ahead and be optimistic about
it and say that yes this is the cyborg
superman hank henshaw although he may or
may not have Kryptonian DNA like I'm
assuming that he does not because he had
that kryptonite knife and it did not
hurt him and just to throw a little more
gasoline on cyborg superman theories
he's a really dark character compared to
john john's typical personality martian
manhunter personality tends to be a
little bit more opaque he's kind of the
straight man that the flash bounces
jokes off like the flash is like the
hyperactive jokey person martian
manhunter is always the person that
reacts to that with blank faces so until
we get some more evidence I'm gonna go
ahead and say that he is the Hank
Henshaw from the comics and they haven't
radically changed his backstory and
turned him into another superhero but if
you do want to believe that he's
secretly Martian Manhunter then I mean
you wouldn't be wrong like there isn't
proof that he is not but just to speak
about the series in general I like the
direction that it's going I think
they've already addressed some of the
complaints that you guys have had about
the pilot just that he got a little bit
preachy but I mean that's the way pilots
tend to be a little bit more
over-the-top than regular episodes just
based on the tone of comments across the
first season of the flash it took about
the first half of the season like by the
time we got to Episode eight like the
big arrow flash crossover that's when
people started to go crazy about the
flash during this first couple of weeks
people were still kind of iffy so I feel
like Supergirl is doing a good job of
picking up momentum and it's still like
four times as popular as most other TV
shows even if half those people stopped
watching it it would still be way more
popular than almost everything else on
TV so if you really follow ratings which
I don't think is a good idea Supergirl
is still incredibly successful but I
don't I don't necessarily look at that
what I'm looking at shows to watch so
just moving into flash territory I'm
gonna play this zoom clip from episode
six this is part two of last week's
episode it's a two-parter for those
didn't know who exactly came up with
this terrible idea
you okay it's not a terrible idea we
make zoom think that Linda is doctor
late and use her to draw him out
it's too dangerous right maybe she
didn't scream every time she fired
take my hand love going through the
breach zoom thumb neglect my body and we
can travel so the big deal here and
especially with some of the images that
they put forward is that zoom looks just
a little bit more muscular than Grant
Gustin even though they're similar sized
so those of you that want to believe
that it is secretly Barry's dad it's
Henry Allen you would not be wrong
that's actually a pretty good pic and
there was this quote that Joe West and a
couple other characters had last week
that I think was really important it's
not murder if it's your doppelganger so
I know a lot of you after the first two
episodes we're asking what's the deal
with Barry killing these metas because
it looked like sandy man died just for
instance I don't necessarily think the
flash is on this murder arc but when dr.
light said it again to she's like I have
to kill her it's not murder if it's your
doppelganger it just got me thinking
about zoom like what is zoom is Barry
and Barry's going to be presented with
the idea of having to murder himself
doesn't that seem like a big CW type
twist CW shows tend to be really big on
drama and what's more dramatic than
having to kill yourself maybe having to
kill your father that's why I really
like the Henry Allen idea and I think
it's a little more cliche to make the
hero the villain for those of you that
don't watch way too much TV
other than I'll go ahead and say a hero
fighting his darker self has been done
so many times across history almost
every single big genre TV show has had
an episode where the hero has to face
the dark version of himself I'm not
gonna be super upset if zoom is buried
like it's not gonna ruin it for me or
anything but I think it'd be more
exciting if it were his dad if it were
John Wesley Shipp and just on my list of
like really awesome zoom choices I feel
like it'd be really awesome if it were
Wally West but I feel like the actor
that plays Wally West is also like
really live in really thin just like
Grant Gustin in the actor in this suit
like whoever they have in this suit
looks way more muscular than that and
just address the eddy theories I know a
lot of you guys want to see Eddie be the
villain because he was kind of like the
hunters
Lamont character in season one that's
why everybody thought he was gonna be
cobalt blue or he was gonna be a version
of the hunters Oh Lamont character from
the comics but Rick cos net is actually
a main cast member on another show on a
different network so I just think
logistically it would be a nightmare to
try and have him on the show but I do
think he'd make a good version of a
reverse flash at some point if they want
to do cobalt blue they can always do
them in the future so what's gonna
happen is is we're gonna have to like
reevaluate our theories after we get a
bunch more zoom scenes but I think after
this episode we'll have a much much
better idea about who he is just listen
very carefully to his dialogue when he
speaks most of the time they'll let's
lit things that will foreshadow the
future like he just written that way
that's the way comic books are written
just because my friends got married this
weekend so I'm running a little bit
behind just because I had a lot of
real-world stuff going on I'm gonna cut
this Q&A short but I will name this
week's giveaway winner so
congratulations to Brendan Burgess you
win a reverse flash ring just be sure to
private message me on the back end of my
channel so I can get your contact info
and then I will start a new round of the
giveaway whenever I post my flash video
on Tuesday but what's gonna happen next
is if I can't get Game of Thrones out
before Walking Dead tonight I'll just
I'll post it on Monday so just look out
on Facebook and Twitter for updates on
when everything is posting tonight if
you don't know where links for like my
Facebook and Twitter and all stuff like
that is that I way down at the bottom of
the description but why you guys wait
for all that stuff to post you can click
here for the International Star Wars
trailer I just posted yeah you can click
here for this week's episode of the
flash and arrow thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight